come ormai avrete capito dopo 15 anni di
canale io ho un'ossessione positiva per
quanto riguarda la televisione fine anni
90 inizio anni 2000
quel periodo lì ne era il periodo
storico in cui si guardava tantissima
televisione di qualsiasi genere internet
era ancora agli albori si è iniziato a
smettere di leggere e l'unica fonte di
intrattenimento se non eri un bambino
privilegiato con tutte le console era il
tubo catodico e sono arrivato alla
conclusione che gli parlarvi di
determinate cose sia il mio destino sia
il motivo per cui io ho aperto questo
maledetto canale e io lo so che non sono
solo anche quando sono solo perché c'è
un sacco di gente che come me è
cresciuta in quel periodo storico
televisivo e ogni tanto sdraiata sul
divano che non fa niente si chiede che
fine ha fatto alessia merz giusto per
mettervi la cosa in prospettiva io è da
qualche anno che su steam
mi chiamo gianni fantoni questo perché
giocando spesso ai giochi multiplayer io
vengo riconosciuto quindi per non
inventarmi un altro nick di sana pianta
ho messo la prima persona che mi è
venuta in mente e due domande me le
dovrei fare se la prima persona che mi
viene in mente e gianni fantoni qualche
anno fa però uscì un videogioco chiamato
nomen sky un gioco in cui si deve
esplorare un universo e scoprire nuovi
pianeti
ogni volta che tu scopri un nuovo
pianeta il gioco di chat tutti gli altri
esploratori il nome della persona che ha
scoperto quel pianeta
io in quel periodo mi chiamavo juliana
moreira ci saranno almeno 100 150
pianeti scoperti da juliana moreira
questo preambolo e soltanto per farvi
capire il mio punto di vista su un
determinato argomento per la storia che
voglio raccontarvi oggi
24 novembre 2017 il canale youtube
dell'akrai carica il primo episodio di
una web series chiamata a casa cry una
sitcom è interamente girata in un cai
con protagonista la premiata ditta prima
di dirvi quanto sia importante questa
storia per il mio bagaglio culturale
risponda a una semplice domanda chi sono
la premiata ditta sono quattro comici
tiziana foschi francesca draghetti
roberto ciufoli e sicuramente
conoscerete pino insegno
il regista del capolavoro ti stramo che
tra gli anni 90 e gli inizi del 2000 con
i loro sketch i loro programmi in tv ea
teatro erano giganteschi
[Applauso]
[Musica]
niente per posta per te per farvelo
capire meglio ho comprato un tv sorrisi
e canzoni di marzo del 2001 con loro in
copertina
a parte il fatto che leggere un tv
sorrisi e canzoni del 2001 è una piccola
porta in un universo che di cui avevo
perso la memoria è pieno di movie in
questa pubblicità c'è una donna
interamente nulla ed è una proposta
della lotto da una parte troviamo le
strisce di lupo alberto dall'altra
daniele luttazzi che fa la pubblicità al
eccoli qua travestiti da anziani questo
riassume perfettamente quello che fosse
l'umorismo ai tempi della premiata ditta
cioè sketch parodie e personaggi e pino
è un entusiasta della vita
tiziana una ragazza con il vizio di
imparare francesca ama la lettura e
soprattutto il veicolo mentre roberto ad
ora al figlio e alla passione per i
cavalli ma sicuramente voi la premiata
ditta ve la ricorderete per le cinque
stagioni di finché c'è vita c'è speranza
e per le quattro stagioni del loro show
in prima serata mediaset
la premiata te le dita
[Applauso]
e loro sono andati avanti per anni e
anni anni a fare lo stesso tempo di
format sketch personaggi parodie e
sketch personaggi parodia il segmento
più vecchio che sono riuscito a trovare
e del 1987 di un programma di enrica
bonaccorti chiamato pronto chi gioca in
cui loro fanno le stesse identiche cose
che avrebbero fatto vent'anni dopo
e soprattutto si rideva che si rideva
che si rideva con loro ditemi dove
potresti mai trovare la sigla dei di
amon cantata dai ricchi e poveri mon
père anni per trovare un argomento al
mese per parlare alla gente poi bastava
i ricchi e poveri è pronto ho anche
comprato due videocassette della
premiata ditta una chiamata show a
29.900 lire che una scappata incredibile
perché sono semplicemente due o tre
puntate di finché c'è vita c'è speranza
tra l'altro videocassetta più libro è il
libro non c'era l'altra videocassetta l
unica cosa effettivamente diversa che
sono riuscito a vedere io fatta da loro
ed è un film lo sapevate
la premiata ditta ha fatto un film
chiamato l'assassino è quello con le
scarpe gialle
io non sapevo di questa cosa l'ho visto
ed è non non un granché non è neanche
orrendo è un film un film regia puoi
fare uno zoom su roberto ciufoli che dal
1995 che non invecchia una virgola e
hanno finito la loro carriera dal gruppo
nel 2006 l'unica cosa che hanno fatto
dopo è stata mi sembra uno spettacolo
una riunion chiamata abbiamo fatto 30
facciamo 31 11 anni dopo nel 2017 sono
tornati per krhin che cos'è casa cry
casa rai è come ho detto prima questa
web series di fatta di episodi da 52
minuti dove fanno rovina un po sketch
comici parodia e personaggi e gis st
pisano è un po come se gli one direction
giorno decidessero di riunirsi per lo
stacchi nono bonanni ha uccisa
la prima delle quattro stagioni di
questa casa cry è la più carina e la
classica base con cui la premiata ditta
ha lavorato per anni ania ne è veramente
un sacco di giochi di parole
nella prima puntata si parla di salame
che salame anche un insulto e quindi in
meno da di milano il salame e insieme
gli dice weber e perché a milano
l'insulto e pirla e la traduzione di
pirla più o meno e salame batman e robin
che cantano noi siamo belle lasceremo
mai
noi siamo belle pipistrelli alludendo al
fatto che siano omosessuali in questa è
una delle mie preferite lui porta una
rapa in cassa e una rapa però un po
troppo piccola questa è una rapina
perché la rapa piccola si può anche dire
col diminutivo di rapina non so se
questo è un pochino elaborata ma è sul
podio anche lei qui c'è diabolica che
viene avvicinato da una fan che chiede
se è ancora single e e quale sia il suo
status coniugale un posto della sua
fidanzata è occupato
mi faceva perché sembra è vacante il
posto da fidanzata ma in realtà la la
compagna di diabolik si chiama e poi
tornando al discorso che l'omosessualità
è sempre divertenti di base senza
neanche mettere un contesto fare due
personaggi omosessuali fa ride e fa
tanto ridere quando vanno nella corsia
della frutta e della verdura
no la patata non aprendo e qualcuno è
riuscito anche a dire nei commenti che
questa stagione è più bella delle ultime
di camera cafè cazzo ti permetti ma
l'apice viene toccato nella puntata 19
in cui c'è il classico maniaco che c'è
in tutti cry a quanto pare quello con
l'impermeabile completamente nudo sotto
fatto tra l'altro da roberto ciufoli che
va a molestare letteralmente molestare
una anziana signora la prima volta è lei
allude al fatto che lui abbia il pene
piccolo prendendo il wurstel quelli più
piccoli
la seconda volta lui ridacchia
guardandosi il pene perché è in
l'erezione in questo caso infatti quando
lui apre impermeabile la signora usa il
suo bene come gradino per andare a
prendere le cose nello scaffale più alto
baby qui si muove tecnico
la seconda stagione invece si
ridimensiona parecchio all'inizio fanno
dei provini del web
una roba tipo paperissima dove loro
guardano questi provini mandati online e
poi scelgono alcuni personaggi da
portare durante le puntate
purtroppo sono soltanto dieci episodi
rispetto ai venti della prima e ci sono
soltanto ciufoli e insegno mancano le
due attrici è molto più debole anche a
livello di scrittura e di sketch c'è
garibaldi che va a fare la spesa
sento per favore non la facciamo non
farà passi la voce male nella terza
stagione c'è un cambio radicale la serie
viene divisa per regioni dove pino
insegno intervista un cuoco per ogni
regione è quel cuoco lo fa sempre per
ogni regione
roberto ciufoli mondo dalla sardegna
l'uomo un grande passo per l'umanità
tutti gli accenti tutti i costumi perché
ciufoli e pelato lì funziona come eat me
li metti cappello la parrucca la barba e
baffi il nasone le cose e funziona e le
battute sono esattamente quelle che
state pensando e non mi hanno deluso in
campania c'è il venditore di calzini e
il molise non esiste molise piatto è per
ora questa rispetto anche alla seconda è
la peggiore di tutte le serie e poi
arriviamo alla quarta stagione uscita
nel 2021
già solo l'aver visto tornare la
premiata ditta era fonte per me di
informazione per voi ma c'è un motivo se
il video non si chiama il ritorno della
premiata ditta ma si chiama
all'incredibile canale youtube della cry
vi faccio vedere come inizia la prima
cosa che si vede e claudio lippi
il video conferenza con lei stiamo
facendo un ottimo lavoro preparatevi
perché voi non avete idea di tichy si è
subito dopo appare il reparto marketing
e il direttore del centro commerciale
sandro che voi vi ricorderete
sicuramente per buona la prima non ci
sono neanche più roberto ciufoli e pin
sentono i due nuovi protagonisti sono
corrado hai sonno fi porca [ __ ]
ricordate di non sia di biase non
proprio freschi freschi come una rosa ma
poteva andare molto peggio subito dopo
la loro parte appare maurizio merluzzo
nel suo show di cucina cotte frullato in
una parodia di di cotto e frullato
nicola theiner coop e marisa laurito è
tutto fatto tu sei disordine schifo
bravo che cazzo mi stai dicendo ci sono
merluzzo nicola dei nirchio per marisa
laurito nella stessa inquadratura
ma che cazzo dici allora futuro perché
nessuno me l'ha detto prima di tutto
secondo come ci siete finiti lì e questa
è la cazzo di prima puntata e le altre
hanno tutte almeno un ospite incredibile
all'interno abbiamo leonardo manera
milena miconi direttamente dal bagaglino
marco della noce texter non quello del
laboratorio di dexter non il serial
killer dexter dexter e chat e mini sul
vostro gara dexter
oggi sono qui per proporvi una sfida
particolare molto piccante
io no marco marzocca giovedì signor
distretto di polizia
debora villa max pisu odio o mio dio e
la professoressa fullin
un consiglio si dà sempre voi e impieghi
lapresse napoli perché nessuno conosce
questa serie e ultimo ma non ultimo
cacioppo che adesso è grosso quando john
cena vene il collo c'è il collo che
parte dal lobo dell'orecchio all'uomo
dell'orecchio gration cena di
quest'ultima stagione valore che vi
possa neanche raccontare molto sono
sempre i soliti sketch leggermente più
strutturati della terza e della seconda
sono un pochino meglio ma l'ultimo
episodio a 3000 visual il nome sul mio
campanello c'è più visual di quella
puntata canzoni claudio lippi e sandro
io non so vi giuro non so per me è come
essere entrato in una dimensione
parallela dove tutto è perfetto tanto
non so neanche se sia andata bene ci
hanno fatto quattro stagioni diverse per
una serie che ha una produzione
altissima per essere una web series ma
nella maniera più assoluta questa è una
cosa che va vista va vista per crederci
va vista per provare a vivere e va vista
per chiuderla nel cassetto secondario
del vostro bagaglio culturale
questi sono i motivi per cui vale la
pena vivere questi quelli più
inaspettati quelli più divertenti e
quelli per cui posso fare un video e
raccontarvelo grazie mille
davvero di cuore
avvocato buon tocco
beh